[Music]
you ever feel like you're being followed
so here we go with uh
an overarching question here because we
first met saul back in i believe season
two of breaking bad and so
just what's your been your perception of
the character saul from the first time
that you met him on the page
prepping for that season as opposed to
where we are now what's the character
how is the character changed i guess
from then to now
are you talking from breaking bad or
from
i mean he's a much richer deeper more
i'd say
relatable
uh character he was very fun to watch in
breaking bad and fun to play
um but he was a very thin
characterization
uh in my mind he uh was a guy who
was putting on this front
as he states he was trying to get the
homeboys trying to get low-level and
mid-level drug dealers and hoping for a
high-level one
and then he went to strip clubs and uh
played golf occasionally on the weekends
he was an empty guy an empty life
uh
and then they invented jimmy mcgill for
a better call saul and he was a guy with
people that he loved a challenging
history of trying very hard to do the
right thing
trying to be a good person
frustrated by life
capable of some things and and a hard
worker but just couldn't find any place
that he felt
vindicated and
respected and appreciated and uh and so
i relate to him a lot more it's just a
great great uh thickening and
um building of character uh the
difference is so big the character i
played in better in breaking bad was
almost a um sketch level you know
care comedy uh uh
characterization
yeah and i do admire the guy's work
ethic especially when you watch better
call saul and so as we get into this
season six can you just give us sort of
maybe the tenor of the conversations
between you and creator vince as far as
themes go away like what what are you
looking to achieve here as we enter into
this final season
well um to be fair uh peter gould uh
and vince gilligan created the show
together
and peter in many ways uh oversaw the
final four seasons of better call saul
uh vince fully rejoined the show in the
final season
um
but it so much had been
handed to peter that any decisions that
were made for this character were
definitely the two of them
if not um even more loaded towards peter
i had a request from
season one on
that
they consider the idea that sometimes
people learn the right lessons from
bad experiences and trauma and
challenges in their life
you know my feeling is that walter white
kind of learned the wrong lessons uh he
became more egotistical
he pursued his weaker and more uh
lesser demons
lesser angels at the very least but
maybe demons
and and that's where he found himself
landing is is in his worst instincts and
i was just suggesting that maybe
after all that they had planned for saul
and
that maybe the character could grow in a
in a beneficial way
um
and i wasn't sure if vince gilligan and
peter gould
who would make that final choice
felt that
they wanted to tell that story or that
that was a legitimate story to tell so
now that i've seen where it ends up
and i've seen i think i influenced them
a bit by talking about that very
question
we created a character who's
at his heart i think more likable than
walter white
we certainly understand the things that
drive him more and he has he seemed to
have tried a lot harder than walter
white did
uh to
to be a good person
he made a very real concerted effort and
we watched him do it on the show to win
his brother over
to be you know becoming a lawyer to do
the right thing
and then his brother iced him out of the
white shoe law firm and
he was just in all kinds of he was just
sad and torn up by that
more than more than anything
um
so all i'll say is i talk to them about
a character and a human being growing
and learning
positive lessons and they
i can't tell you where we end up and i
wouldn't say it's a simplistic
choice
but i think maybe they were affected by
my hopes and concerns that
and my pitch
that
at least partially sometimes people can
learn the right lessons from the
challenges of life yeah i don't know i
don't know if i'm speaking in such
generic terms but
you don't have to because you want to
preserve the our excitement and the
secrecy around season six and i just
wonder if part of jimmy's desire to sort
of grow in a different way to be a
redeemable character in some sense is
related to his relationship with kim
wexler because because you watch how
great seahorn is at playing that role
and you your two's dynamic i mean we
hear her say in the season six trailer
do you think we're wicked so i wonder if
part of jimmy is just
is maybe looking out for her or maybe
concerned that she is going down an
irredeemable path
yeah he's always thinking about that
he's always concerned for her and he
does worry that he
is taking her to a bad place but of
course at the end of season five we see
this moment where it looks like she
is igniting
the uh
more dangerous choice
in the pursuit of danger and ethical
compromise
but we'll see i can't tell you she's
definitely a part they're they they they
have the most fun
when they're working together on a scam
it's it's very inspiring to a lot of the
couples out there to just have a fun
little time doing some scam at a
restaurant or something see what happens
and better call saul but one of my
favorite things about watching how the
show is laid out is you're budding
rivalry with howard and and we see a
reference to that in the season six
trailer too as a sports fan i kind of
look at it as like the lakers kings nba
rivalry from the early 2000s where you
have a clear underdog
and a clear champion so
how much fun has that been to play that
underdog character going up against
against the big champ
i love it i can relate to
that partially
um i'm not a person who carries
resentments
um
i i see great value in dropping them and
throwing them away
so jimmy is very different from me in
his willingness to uh
to hold on to her feelings and and look
for someone to blame and yet i do relate
to his
frustration and feeling that
howard has had it easy and should be
taken down a peg or two we'll see what
happens
yeah the what really hooked me into
season five was right off the bat was
that scene where we're watching gene and
he's just trying to mind his own
business sitting on the bench at the
mall and then somebody approaches him
and and he's been outed so to speak and
so when he makes that phone call to the
late great robert forrester's character
what do you think is going through
jimmy's mind at that moment when he has
that change of heart when he's prepared
to just move on again but then he says
no i'm staying here
what's your take on what's going on in
jimmy's noggin
i think that it's probably really hard
to um
hide
in a in a false name
and live a quiet life if you're a
outgoing
you know colorful personality like jimmy
i don't think that's an easy life to
live that he's been living uh in hiding
as jean czechovic
um and i think um
he's had enough and he realizes i i can
keep running but
it doesn't matter how much money i've
saved up
uh it doesn't what am i protecting this
life is not worth protecting
that's what i think he's thinking
because even just playing him in the you
know moments that you act the scene of a
guy who
is quiet shut down
literally like doesn't want to talk too
much doesn't want people to notice him
doesn't can't share who he is especially
a valuable character like jimmy who's
got to shut himself off completely that
would not be an easy thing to keep going
for years
and i don't know when you ask yourself
you know oh [ __ ] i gotta shut it down i
gotta i gotta go home i can't go out i
can't meet anyone
why am i doing this
so i can keep doing this
i don't know if that's worth it
you know what i mean yeah i was
wondering how a comic what would handle
being in the witness protection program
because it's like at some point you just
feel the need you're gonna do an open
mic at some point doesn't matter where
you're yeah listen i met i met abby
hoffman um he gave a speech at my school
he had a book out
uh
and uh you know he he was in hiding from
the fbi and
he had plastic surgery and everything
and uh
the next time he sort of came to public
consciousness
he was on the front page of his local
paper because he was leading
a uh
a protest movement to clean up the river
in town
so the point is here he is in hiding
and what does he do what does he do
after getting plastic surgery and
changing his name and going into hiding
he leads a
protest movement that puts his picture
on the front page of the paper
and i just keep i always think about
that when i think about gene and how
he's you can't suck up who you are i
mean you can but it it's not good for
you and it's hard
yeah you can only be uh henry hill
getting the paper for so long before you
go you know before you feel that
temptation again yeah i mean look at
look at henry hill
yeah i mean
you know as as i sort of continue the
highlights of season five here that i
love i mean the the episode of bagman
was such a riveting episode to watch
was that the most
physically punishing
sequence at that action scene in in the
desert was that to to that point anyway
was that the toughest
sequence to pull off in your career
uh walking around in the desert for
14 days in 112 degree heat
is that what you're talking about i'm
sweating my apartment asking the
question
yeah it was tough there are scenes that
are very emotional and kind of
about an impacted emotion
um that that we see occasionally and
better call saul
he's got a lot of feelings left over
from his childhood that are welling up
inside him and that he's tamping down
but occasionally it all comes to a head
those are challenging scenes to do
but uh yeah wandering the desert was
really hard physically really hard and
and dangerous for everybody involved the
crew
and the cast you know but
we took a lot of precautions
and we figured it out eventually it took
a few days but we got it
under control
i loved the uh the sort of reunion scene
i guess it was really your first
interaction with hank and steve that we
got to see in season five how much fun
was that to to just kind of pull off
because you get to see them again do you
go back to breaking bad to kind of study
your your interactions that took place
after that
i feel like the soul i played in
breaking bad is not hard for me to
access he is not like
he's fun as hell
he's a a whole bunch of ticks and and
inspirations
and i can i can just
grab a hold of that very easily
so i don't have to study that guy uh i
do have to study jimmy
jimmy's got a lot more going on he's got
a lot more feelings a lot more basically
more psychology at work um more voices
in his head pulling him in different
directions
saul is easy
up front
you know he's just a front and he's uh
selfish and
that's the bottom line it's like what do
i need to get what do i need to say or
do to get what out of you what i want to
get out of you
and that's his whole that's everything
that's happening that's the only thing
that's happening
yeah and as we wrap things up on on the
finale i mean the finale of the show
where are your uh
emotions at is there is there relief is
there excitement or is there trepidation
do you do anything special when the
season finale airs coming up
uh i think it will be a big
moment for me to watch that finale i um
i haven't really said goodbye to the
character yet i've had this guy in my
life for 12 years i've had obviously
some pretty big breaks in there in
between seasons even in between the
shows
so i'm very used to having a break and
then going back to him i think it'll
only be on seeing uh see in that final
episode the finale that i'll feel like
oh wow
that's it
well you know what they say
the wicked flea when no man pursueth
[Music]
you think we're wicked i i got a couple
fun questions and i'll start with sort
of like an an overarching uh question
about your character gus fring
how is he able to stay
two steps ahead of everyone else why do
you think it is that he's able to read
people
so well
well he's you know
in many ways evolve a different
direction than most human beings
he understands himself
on a level that's beyond he knows when
he's anxiety has anxiety impatience
frustrated but he also
thinks
can put himself in other people's shoes
and think about what they might do
and what options they have at their
disposal
he has more options at his disposal and
he doesn't show his hand even to those
he who worked for him so diligently and
that's what puts you ahead
because he knows what he wants in the
end and he knows it's going to be a step
back
one step back two steps back but four
steps forward when the time comes
yeah he reminds me of like uh like a
magic or a larry in the nba where they
just see the court and they see two
steps ahead of everything and and
they're not the fastest they're not the
quickest but they just know what's going
to happen the the stoicism is also
something that's really intriguing to me
because you and the character mike
played by jonathan banks are the two
most stoic characters in in the entire
show so
what do you think gus
understands about mike and his mentality
he understands that mike is a worker bee
he understand that mike is could be a
very formidable opponent for him but
mike is someone who wants to be told he
wants also for his opinion to be heard
if you saw episode one and two of season
six mike starts to speak up a little bit
in a way that
has him under us as an audience
understand even though he's stoic he has
feelings
oh
and gus sees that
and then he has to limit
how he interacts with mike because mike
has gotten close to him not the first
time to someone that could compromise
all of our freedom all of our family so
i think it's the mutual admiral
the
it's a mutual respect that that he has
for mike until
mike shows his hand in regard to nacho
varga
that he
gus has to go oh okay
he
is in too deep
giving a guy credit for things that he
should have credit for that i feel as
gustavo fring as well but that aren't
going to help the organization
so as as far as you and actor and
jonathan banks and those wonderful
scenes you all have together can you
sort of give me a a bird's eye view and
take me inside of what those
conversations are like before you have a
crucial scene what's that interaction
from the actor's perspective i love
jonathan jonathan wants to get it done
so do i and so if there are some
moments where we have
minimal conversations about certain
things and other moments where we look
at each other and we literally this
season
uh
i'm not going to talk about this today
and i go i feel the same way you know
we're we are so much on the same page
and have the same style of working
that oh we should talk about this you
know
so we we it's it's amazing how in
concert we are and sometimes when he
doesn't want to talk i push him because
i'm gustavo frank and i'm i'm preparing
myself for being for the camera roll and
even though he says i don't talk about
this i start talking about it just to
piss him off
because he can be a crotchety dude
and
as such
you see that in mike he doesn't suffer
fools
jonathan is a smart man
and so
but i am as well and so i like to play
with him in a way that is reminiscent or
that is is is kind of reflective of what
gus does but in a more playful fashion
and then i just turn off the faucet
when i have to
and that look i give him says
oh
so you're not going to hit your mark
you're going to be in front of your mark
okay
if you're going to be in front of your
mark i'm going to be here in my mind i
just do it and the cameraman goes
jonathan could you go a little to your
left
well i'm on my mark
yeah and i know and i speak right up and
go yeah i'm not on mine for a reason
because last take you weren't on yours
so you know what i mean and i just
pushed the envelope which i think he
acknowledges and realizes and so do i
that it's a playful little game that
gets serious when we drop into character
and it works
hey if i'm the director from the dp
y'all are the two people i'm not telling
you where your mark is
it's not like you don't do what you want
to do i do not want to get in the way of
this process i i did get to check out a
couple of the episodes uh for season six
and and even in the season six trailer
we see that there's going to be a
meeting between gustavo and and hector
salamanca
what is going into that conversation
what do you see gus's mentality as being
as it relates to
hector
look gus you know why would they meet
again
right
why i'm asking you that question
well i would imagine that there's
something
that hector wants to know
i would imagine that there's something
that gustavo
needs to know
to figure out what his next moves might
be
and that takes looking into a man's eyes
be and seeing where that person gus's
perception is off the charts he reads
people like no other i do it in my own
life because i take it i take in
everything it's a hyper vigilance that
gustavo has and the only way you can get
that answer
is to look at someone in the in the face
and you know what mark margolis is a
great actor can hide everything
and gus is also a great poker player and
can can hide everything but somewhere in
that meeting
you're gonna you're gonna as an audience
be so excited to either see it or not
and have a clue or not this show man
it's it's mind-boggling how it keeps you
on the edge of your seat in season six
gustavo friend has to be the greatest
actor of all time
it really does it's an actor within an
actor and so now you just got me
salivating at the possibility thinking
that it's not just hector and gustavo
who have that meeting of mines but it's
also you and mark as actors who are
maybe playing a little bit of poker with
one another in that scene there's no
doubt about it there's no doubt about it
the audience is going to be so excited
by it because and you're going to want
to know did he get his answer
from on
on both characters behalf
did you know hector get his answer did
gus get his answer and you're going to
be strung out and you're gonna have to
watch a little more and then you it's
gonna hit you oh my god
oh my god he knew exactly what that
answer was and he got confirmation or
not
i was i was reading an interview that
you had done a couple years ago you were
talking about the character of gus and
and you said something that really stuck
with me that you never saw him as being
a truly evil character you don't see a
character as being truly evil but maybe
misunderstood so
what what do you think
we misunderstand or maybe the characters
in the show misunderstand about gus and
where he's coming from i think they they
we have to be reminded of his of the
story he tells hector in the hospital i
think he's back in season four that
tells you about his previous life
like all right so gus you know he grew
up poor he had to figure it out they you
know he had to take care of himself and
his family he became fierce
you know the coyote the whole story
about this animal
you know how he was compassionate took
care of it all these things you know
that tells you a lot about him he came
from a place of in a way vulnerability
and not having what he always wanted
so for me the analogy is oh
he's that part of him tapped into a part
of me that is the little kid who didn't
get what he wanted he didn't get taken
care of he had to fight for everything
he has
screw you and then you're gonna sit here
and you're gonna tell me you're gonna
take credit for me being who i am no i
laid that down every part of it i
figured this out so when you think about
gus in that way
it's like holy
you know he's taking responsibility
i think for me i have to find the
humanity in a character i play because
that's what you relate to as a human
being like what decision would you make
he's making the decisions that come out
of his past
and he's making those decisions in his
present and he's making those decisions
for his future that's part of your gig
is sending people into scary spots like
such as with nacho so i'm just curious
how gus feels about that does gus feel
empathy for these people is it just uh
they're expendable and they're just
means to an end they're expendable for
lalo salamanca i hate that bastard he
doesn't care about human life he doesn't
care about people gustavo does
yeah he's not going to show you every
time
like mike is saying hey let the kid did
us assault that kid excuse me that kid
didn't do us a solid he played he played
the wrong cards and he hung himself
right and you know does gus feel for him
yes of course does he know the kid loves
his father he's a good kid and all that
yes but he made decisions against what
gus
against gus when he decided that he was
going to kill hector salamanca
and that pissed us off that's gus's that
was reserved for gus for this
long-standing hatred he had for hector
so he didn't come to the boss and
confined in the mastermind too bad does
gus feel for him yes he puts all these
people in situations where they're gonna
be compromised but you know what that's
what a good chess player does that's why
you have pawns
he feels but he still has to get
checkmate at some point um
it's the long game it's the end game gus
is a mastermind and yes he does things
that you may think are cold and brutal
but you know what those things keep him
alive to be able to run the big
operation that he's eventually going to
run
from breaking bad to better call salt
have you learned anything new about gus
was the character already there and
fully formed and breaking bad or do you
feel like you've uncovered some new
layers of your character i feel in this
season six i've been uncovered so many
new layers that when i go in to do some
additional sound recording digital
recording i go oh no wait i know i want
to reshoot that no that's to this or two
that and then i go
no no
this is not that guy you used to play in
breaking bad
like i want to control the chaos i want
to be the big head honcho i want to be
the guy you listen to i wanted to be the
guy that i'm the be all and last word
you know in episode six of better call
saul that's not always the case for gus
and he's got to figure out a way it's a
new and different gust i'm so pleased to
have been able and proud that's what
it's like to be an actor to figure out
and how to be present always and deal
with what you're given i'll let you go
with this i just ask you to complete
this sentence when you read the script
for the final episode of this show
what was your reaction
i was speechless
i was absolutely speechless
how could you do this
what brilliant mind
thought up this ending
who's here to see saul goodman
[Music]
you're the guy right
what guy is that
[Music]
very excited about season six um but i i
want to start with that season five
finale it was so intense for both of
y'all really michael i want to start
with you because we always know nacho to
be so like cool and calm and collected
but we saw real dread there at the end
of this past season where do you go for
inspiration
how is that
as an actor how are you able to show
that after you've showed so little with
your poker face leading up to that
ah thank you so much man i mean that
scene is all about loyalty you know he
he he he declares his utmost loyalty to
mike ermentrout you know nacho's a
character who's trying to break good
he's he's probably the only character
who's trying to break good in the whole
breaking bad universe and maybe jesse
pinkman as well and there you know and
in that final season he declares his
cards and there's no more running
because he knows that now the whole
world everybody in that salamanca
territory is going to know
that he works for gus
and that he's a double agent and then
that in that moment he puts everything
on the line that's that cliffhanger
that's that feeling of of saying i'm i'm
loyal to the one guy i know has a moral
core
in this whole world one guy who's
virtuous who doesn't want to see
innocent people die and that's mike
armentrout and i believe him and i are
made her the same claw are cut from the
same cloth and he puts everything on the
line for
in that in that trusting relationship
that's what that was
yeah and you're talking about mayhem
tony you certainly got a lot with that
that shootout uh it was just it was
amazing to watch unfold how much fun or
challenging as an actor is it to have an
action sequence like that that closes
out a season
it was great somebody uh that
interviewed us today said that he that
that reminded him of
kevin mcallister in home alone meets
john wick
because you know the frying pan and
everything um it was great man it was
super fun you know you uh these guys
what they do is it's like um like mike
was saying this they take their time you
know they they they don't rush to to put
everything up on on the screen
and then when when when the ship hits
the fan they really go all in for it you
know i mean even that tunnel man they
created this huge terminal on in one of
the one of the back lots and they had
this long arm with the camera at the end
and it was just like all right you know
get in the tunnel and just go as fast as
you can so that you know the camera is
chasing you and um i mean that thing was
humongous it was super long it was
amazing that they did all that just for
that one little moment you know
and some of my favorite scenes from the
past season were with nacho and lala
where we know nacho is a mole but but
but your character tony isn't aware yet
i'm just curious as actors leading into
those conversations into those scenes
what are you all conversations like
about how to play those roles
i don't think we talked about it at all
right tony did we ever talk i don't
think we i don't think we ever had a
conversation about that at all i i know
that like on on the on the bob and ray
side they really like to rehearse but in
the cartel world man no one rehearses
they don't tell us anything man they
don't tell us anything
the way that i look at it sometimes it's
like you know it's like life i don't
know what's gonna happen tomorrow you
know so
you know you don't know where your
character is going so you kind of just
uh live for the moment you know
yeah and it's a thing it's a ping pong
too you know between the actors and the
writers that vince and peter are such
unbelievable
structural guys they know exactly what
they want but they also allow the actors
to give their own interpretation and
infuse it and infuse so much of the life
of the character in the silences like a
character like nacho barely speaks so
they they allow you to do a lot and then
they actually
kind of go back and ping-pong off of
what you're doing so it's like a back
and forth between what you're doing in
front of the cameras what the writers
are seeing and so there's a nice dance
like that as well which makes it
exciting
this is fascinating then
for you tony because you have this
tremendous scene it gets pretty tense
between jimmy and and kim so they love
to rehearse and then you just kind of
come in freewheel and what was filming
that scene like were there a lot of
rehearsals for that or did you just kind
of have the cameras roll and go for it
yeah no you mean the scene where we're
in uh in the apartment in jim's
apartment
yeah no we rehearsed that tom tom stamps
wrote and directed that that that
episode and tom is i mean
tom is brilliant he's so good at what he
does and he's so great and uh we we
rehearsed that like a day before
maybe a couple days before i don't
remember but i mean we we showed up
there and we did like the whole thing
and he wanted to see how everything
i love it don't get me wrong i mean it's
it's uh like i said before it's a little
bit like theater you know you you get
into it you find things you see where
you're gonna stand you see where this is
going so that when you show up there on
the set you don't you have a little bit
more of an idea where uh or where you're
of where
what you're doing and where you're going
so i mean it was great i mean also i
think it made a difference i think it
made
that scene that much better the fact
that we
we had time to kind of settle into it
and see
how because tom was very clear and kind
of what he wanted like there was there
was even a moment like i think when
she's yelling at me and yelling back at
me or something where i'm staring at her
and tom was like i want you to stare at
her for a long time like just stand
there and stare at her so i'd stare at
her and then i'd walk out and go no no
no longer man just stare at her like you
don't know
what the hell like you the audience
don't know
if he's just going to pull out a gun and
shoot her in the face you know which
once you see it you're like that was
good man that was great i would have
just walked out right away you know and
it's sort of those little things that
rehearsals really make a difference
you're so great with your verbiage and
then michael you mentioned earlier that
nacho really doesn't have a whole lot of
dialogue you're doing a lot of this
stuff just with your eyes with your
emotions and so as we look into season
six a little bit you're pretty much on
the run so how do you
you know what's going on in nachos mind
i guess as we kick off season six
wow well for as far as the acting is
concerned you know it was a great lesson
in being you know the character of nacho
is unlike anything i've ever done i come
from the theater you know i i love doing
shakespeare and it was all about like
how much words how much the more lines
you had the better it was right and with
a character like nacho you you learn to
be
and and um and to live the experience
and that experience starts off in season
six
like i said man the whole world's
looking for him you know everybody
everybody in the cartel right now is
looking for him and he's he's a
dangerous person whoever gets their
hands on him first whether it's the
cartel or gus he's very very liable now
he he knows everything you know he he's
he knows the salamanca knows what he's
done and if they find out that through
him that gus has done what he's done
that's world war three right there in
the cartel world so he's um
it's uh i can't just heart pounding man
it's a great cinema dramatic tense
roller coaster
and i'm so excited about how we wrap
things up here in season six and so i i
did promise tony that i wasn't gonna ask
any spoilers i have horse spoilers the
words star wars are muted on my twitter
my question good man you did good so far
just
here's the question is when you get that
script for the final episode and you
read it and you turn that last page
is it a word is it a sentence what were
y'all's reaction personally i was i mean
i was jumping up and down i could not
believe it i mean it was like holy sh
what
what
really we're gonna do this really okay
let's go for it
yeah mike
i just gratitude
honestly i i i just feel
you know it takes it takes a a lot of
hard work
to to be in a position like this but it
takes a lot of luck and and you and you
ask yourself you know why me why why us
why did we get this incredible
opportunity and uh i just felt
incredibly grateful
and responsible i i felt like i needed
to give back and be as generous and as
good to others as i could because the
world was very good to me and and i
needed to give back that's really how i
felt
you don't ever think because we get this
prequel spin off to breaking bad what a
prequel spin-off series would look like
for for either wallow or or for i'll
start with you michael what is a prequel
like for nacho what is that show like
man look
let's let people see season six first as
far as spin-offs are concerned that's a
vince and peter question they're the
masters of of this world and and um we
trust them a hundred percent so whatever
direction they want to go
we're behind them 100
but let's let's get through season six
first
uh tony i guess i'll close out with you
here uh your character is just so
charismatic but also has this very
intimidating intensity and i'm just
curious if you look to as far as
inspiration goes to anybody throughout
history throughout entertainment to kind
of get a sense of where your character's
coming from yeah i had a little bit of a
um
sort of um
jules winfield kind of um
idea about this character you know from
sam jackson from pulp fiction sort of
this you know i'm sorry did i break your
concentration kind of thing you know
where's this kind of guy who's kind of
very easygoing i'm the
master you know but then when it gets
serious he's um
he's scary as hell so i i kind of tried
to tap into a bit of jeweled wingfield
as far as lava was concerned
salamancas guy
[Music]
are you building a case against jimmy
i'm just getting warmed up
so i want to start with the trailer for
season six where we see kim ask howard
if he's building a case against jimmy
and and you said you're just getting
warmed up so
in your eyes are we about to see a new
side of howard in this season
well you know uh
peter and vince and that whole writing
staff have given me as an actor such
wonderful things to play with over the
course of the seasons right i started
off as vader according to you know jimmy
and then i put kim in the corn field and
they hated me and then
and then the whole chuck thing i got a
little sympathy not a lot but a little
sympathy um but now with the you know
season five ending with kim doing the
pistols saying let's go after howard
i think people are like ooh watch out
but you know to my mind you know she's
doing it in pajamas and they're not real
guns so really what's going on and jimmy
doesn't seem very on board so that
teaser that got my curiosity too i was
like what's going to go on there and uh
the great thing about these this writing
team is they've given howard a bunch of
different sides so i think i think i can
say without giving you anything well
you're definitely going to see a
different side of howard this time we've
had kind of a different side for the
first five seasons so
you know given what the events are going
to happen i think you'll definitely see
a different color
yeah and it's almost like i'm curious as
to whether howard is is more concerned
for kim the person going down a a wicked
path or or do you think it's more he's
just concerned about what kim and
you know now jimmy saul can do if they
team up against him
well i mean look they've already thrown
bowling balls on my jaguar they've
already said
much honestly that's
can there be any greater affront to
howard and his sensibilities
so uh so i don't know if there's a fear
factor in there but i uh
i think the idea that howard i i still
make the argument howard has been the
most consistent character in the entire
universe of better call saul he has been
trying to maintain a healthy law firm
from the beginning of those meddling
mcgill brothers and that crazy kim
wexler have just stirred the pot and as
of last season you know i washed my
hands of jimmy that great scene directed
by melissa bernstein when i'm i'm
walking out of the courthouse and he's
becoming unhinged
and i also wash my hands of you know kim
as well you know she you know laughs at
me when i tell them what's going on so
ah
i don't know
listen to me i'm like a dad on the show
like you just you had just listened to
me
and you're you're such a routine
oriented character that you're sort of
like adult life goals uh you know like
we want to have those sort of priorities
right we want to take our vitamins every
morning and work out then go to work but
it it makes those scenes all the more
interesting where you do
uh get get a curve ball thrown at you
like like when you and jimmy are having
that conversation about who's to blame
for for chuck's death it what was that
moment like for for you the actor and
then for howard the character
well i mean
there's two things one
through the course of the of the show
howard does get to speak uh but you know
brevity is the soul of wit is where he
comes from so with a lot of my scenes
with jimmy jimmy is much more loquacious
so as a practical matter uh as an actor
i would sit there and i'd watch bob you
know spin these yarns and do this stuff
which he's so so good at and so there
was a reversal there uh the opening
season before when you know i come and
have the big confession where i think i
killed chuck
and i realized i suffered just like out
of you know the first acting class i
ever had i'm going in and my friends and
scene partners bob and ray are sitting
there and they're being supportive by
listening and watching me emote and work
my way through this monologue but of
course halfway through it part of my
brain goes
oh they're so bored they can't believe
how bad you are
so so kids out there who want to be
actors it never goes away that's for
sure yeah i was going to say it doesn't
matter how big of a show you land you're
always going to have that little fairy
on your shoulder that doubts your craft
at some point
you know speaking of craft i've always
been a huge fan of michael mckeon
do you have like a favorite scene that
you all got to do together because the
interactions were so dynamic on the show
i mean i i call him the mighty michael
mckean because he came locked and loaded
for so many things he's such an
intelligent actor and i say that because
he's aware of everything that's
happening he's also very responsive so
if i'm throwing something he immediately
goes with this this whole thing
i used to always think this whenever i
opened up the script and i see it was a
scene with me and mckeen i thought oh
okay at least it's going to be good
because he's in it and it felt like
playing tennis with somebody who was a
tennis master i always felt like i came
back
away from the scene a little bit better
um what a gift i had is the final scene
that him and i had together that entire
day was shot in sequence you almost
never get that in television and so it
started with
him in the conference room and me giving
him the check and then it moved into him
leaving and the last time i saw michael
mckean on the set of better call saul i
was standing at hhm
leading the applause as he stood down
there and i walked off and then
literally the way production works
they're like okay that's it all right
patreon so i stayed upstairs and went
and he like got in the car and he went
home and i didn't see him for like four
months
it was really art imitating life but i
tell you what anybody who gets a chance
to work alongside of him is lucky
yeah i mean i i've been a fan since clue
you know um when
when you think about and now getting to
work with with odenkirk so closely as
well i love i love the way that you all
have this rivalry built because i was
talking to bob about it and it's almost
like i'm an nba fan so it's like the the
lakers kings early 2000s where you had
this young you know upstart underdog but
then you had the established champ
that's you so how do you see that
rivalry and how has it evolved as we get
into season six
wow you know i think um
i think howard has always suffered under
the idea of like is is is he worthy of
the of the crown is he worthy of the h
because truck was sort of the brains of
the organization but with truck being
gone
i think howard has been able to
ascend into a sense of self he's also
allowed himself to grow
the whole going to therapy and figuring
all that stuff but that's a big deal for
somebody like howard hammond and look
what's great is that the writers also
give him he's he's become enlightened
but he's the kind of guy who's
enlightened by putting namaste on his
jag so you know
that's that's
he's trying he's trying the best he can
but i think at this point the idea of
him sort of being a father figure which
i've always thought howard was looking
out for jimmy and looking out for kim
at some point you know uh even the best
of parents have to say i have done my
best and you know i'm i'm not going to
not going to give you any more there's
no more handouts you got to fend for
yourself
yeah you got to watch you got to wash
your hands of it
it's it's i'm thinking now because we
got spoiled with breaking bad and then
we got this amazing prequel we got a
breaking bad sort of sequel movie i'm
just curious what a howard hamlin
prequel show would look like who was
this guy in his formative years
i think it was probably some uh
ill-fitting clothing playing a lot of
tennis poorly you know what i'm saying
my socks were definitely halfway up the
calf and they never went down um
i think howard was probably a little
more awkward
and the reason you you talked about it
before there's a an adulting that howard
has and i think it's a learned thing i
think howard has a stack of books like
the dale carnegie sort of how to win
friends and influence people sort of
thing and howard took to that he took to
the four agreements he took to all of
that stuff um
and he lives it in the front of his
brain
not deep in his heart so he knows all
the mannerisms and he knows what to do
and how to address and all that but it
doesn't come naturally but in in these
last two seasons i think the writers
have given him a key to maybe give him
hope for a second half of his life where
things are a little easier and maybe the
ties and stuff maybe he loses the tie
bar in the second half
i got one more question and then then
i'll let you go and it's a simple one
you can feel free to answer it however
you want what was your reaction
to reading that final script i'm not
looking for spoilers i'm just curious
what was your one word one sentence your
emotional reaction to seeing what was on
the page
um i guess satisfying
um
i don't know
yeah there's a reason i'm an actor and
not a writer and not uh an executive
producer i
i don't see the big picture
i don't know how people encompass seeing
that and then how you how you steer that
ship home into a into a port where
everybody gets off safely
and happily and and i'm talking from an
audience perspective
and yet these guys
and so when i read the final script and
i turned the final page
you know there's that
that bittersweet moment of like
that's how it ends and yet i was like
that's the right way to end look at me
getting all soft and emotional you're
gonna love it rocks
you